aqui eu tenho uma Alerta importante que
eu já mencionei em vários vídeos o
paracetamol é frequentemente recomendado
por tratamento sintomático da dengue
Porque tem uma eficácia como antitérmico
e analgésico contudo é preciso ter uma
atenção especial com esse medicamento
especialmente considerando os riscos de
sobrecarga hepática de sobrecarga ao
fígado a dengue pode afetar esse órgão
tornando crucial a escolha de
medicamentos que não exerçam pressão
adicional sobre esse órgão Vital Nesse
contexto a de pirona surge como uma
alternativa preferencial dado a sua
segurança em relação à função hepática e
o menor risco de exacerbam de problemas
hepáticos em pacientes com dengue Além
disso é fundamental evitar o uso do as
ou ácido acetilsalicílico devido a seu
potencial para aumentar o risco de
sangramentos esse cuidado é
especialmente importante em uma doença
como a dengue que pode comprometer a
coagulação do sangue e aumentar a
suscetibilidade a complicações
hemorrágicas